日本の皆さんこんにちははじめしちです
はじめ社長に4億円の家を買って結構月日
が経ったんですけれどもだいぶここでの
生活に慣れてきました今更なんですけど
いや本当今更なのよもう広すぎて4階建て
なんですけども正直その回に行かない日も
あるし1日のうちで使わない部屋が多すぎ
たり生管理が全く届いてないんですよ広
すぎてそんな4億円のはじめ社長のお家な
んですけれども僕の生活の拠点がねもう
ほぼ決まってきておりまして基本的に初め
社長は4億円の家の4階に住んでますはい
編集撮影生活も4階で基本的にやってるん
ですけど正直ねあのちょっと贅沢なこと
言ってしまうんですけども住むならこれ
ぐらいでいい住むなら本当これぐらいの
スペースがあれば十分なんですよ人って
多分もう4階建てとか1人で住よじゃない
のよ絶対それぐらい広い4億円のおちなん
ですけれども今日何をしようかと言います
と
あのあ来た飽きましたもう嫌に飽きたわけ
ではなくてちょっとこの4階にずっといる
から4階にに飽きてきてしまったのでお
部屋の模様替えがっつりしたいと思います
そもそもこの4階が今どうなってるのか
ちょっと紹介したいと思いますまずは
ルーツはいというわけで紹介したいと思い
ますここが玄関ですねエレベーターから
入れるし階段からも入れますなんかね金の
家具がいいって聞いてから金色の家具置く
ようにしててちょっとゴージャスな感じに
はなってますここが入り口ですはいでこう
やっていくとここがまキッチンとんだろう
リビングって感じなのかなポケモンだっ
たりピチの置き物がいっぱいあったり
キッチンとかもそこにありますねここは
もうほぼリビングとして扱って
ますスイッチとかもここでやってますで奥
に行く
とここがまあ寝室ですねはい基本的に俺
最近後輩といつも寝てるんでベッドが2つ
になってるんですけども寝室がちょっと
味気ないのか
な
うーんなんかほとベッド2個バーンみたい
な感じですごい寂しいなと思って
ますでここがなんか廊下ですねおしゃれな
家具もちょっとつけてみました
シャンデリアとかもあり
ますはいでここが世界一黒い部屋ですもう
ずっと放置してあるけどさすがにそろそろ
何かしようかなと思ってますでさっき撮っ
てた場所ここが今の撮影部屋です
ね
広い編集用の机があったりとかあと空間
めちゃくちゃ広いんだよなソファーこん
だけ置いてもめっちゃスペースあるし棚と
かなんかいかい照明とかも置いてあります
ここねちょっと撮影部屋としては広すぎて
なんかどう使っていいかわからないという
か多分ね俺割と汚い空間が好きというか物
が溢れてる空間が好きなことに気づきまし
た散らかってるとかではないんですけども
なんか程よいサイズ感の場所が好きなん
だろうなっていうのにこの家に住んで
気づきましたまここが撮影部屋券後輩と
カードゲームゲして遊んだり編集した
りっていう場所ですあまりに広すぎるそれ
にしてはでその奥に行くとえゲーム配信
部屋がありますここはもうこれでいいよ
なっていう感じはしますねはい僕の生活
空間は大体この4部屋ですねキッチンとか
あるリビングと奥の寝室のお部屋撮影部屋
という名の中何でもできる部屋そして
ゲーム配信部屋この4つなんですけれども
俺がちょっと変えたいのはですねこの
なんか色々するお部屋撮影とかもできます
よっていう部屋をあの
スイートルームいたいにしたいはい
スイートルームスイートルームスイート
ルームにしたいんですはいなんかベッド2
つあるじゃんで寝室もベッド2つだけ置い
てあるのすごいなんか味気ないというか
そのなんか
あのエロくないというか別にエロくしたい
わけじゃないんですけどもホテルのさ
スイートルームとかってそのベッドの他に
もいろんななんかラジュ割りな家具がある
じゃないですかこれとかめっちゃ高いし
高い家具何個かあるんですけども全然
ラグジュアリじゃないんですよもっと
ラグジュアリな空間にベッドを置いて
おしゃれな出剣なんかゲームとかもできる
よみたいなここをスイートルームにしたい
それが私のたった1つの願いですで逆に
寝室はどうするかとあそこはもうゴリゴリ
の撮影部屋にしたいですただ分けたいと
思うんですよもう動画の部屋とこのラグジ
アリナプライベートの
空間多分ここでも取ることになると思うん
ですけどなんかこんだけ広いとなんか後輩
とかも入れるしカードゲームとかゲームで
も遊んでます広すぎると多分なんかあの
楽しいこといっぱいで集中できんなので
もう寝室を完全にに撮影部屋にしてそして
この部屋はベッドも置きつつあの
ラグジュアリーな家具を置きつつ逆に
ラグジュアリーじゃない家具は排除最高の
スイートルームみたいにしたいと思います
ので早速模様替えしていきたいと思います
レッツ
ゴー今日はこの盗賊2人に来てもらいまし
たよろしくお願いしますこの部屋をベッド
2個あるじゃんここに入れてゲームできる
ようにしてスイートルームにしたいのよね
で逆に奥の寝室を撮影部屋にしたいとはい
はい
はいじゃお願いしますえ嘘だちょっと
ちょっと家具色々あるんですけれども
ややこしいので1回この部屋の家具全部
出し
[音楽]
ますはいというわけでこの部屋にあるもの
を全てどかしました今からこの広い
スペースをいかにスイートルームにできる
か腕の見せところです俺多分人生経験上
スイートルームに泊まったこと
がさ34回ぐらいかな34回ぐらいあり
ますあの女の子とも止まったことあって
すごい楽しかったですというわけで早速
まずベッド絶対必須なのでベッド持ってき
たりしてちょっと早速彩っていきたいと
思い
ますエレガントに欠かせないものそれは金
のラゲージありな
家具
おいいじゃんこういう金の家具でちょっと
ラグジなり要素を見せていきたい
です
ビットのイメージこうバンバンなん
おいラグジこいつらはラグラジリじゃ
ないなんかなんかラスっぽいな
や1人暮らし1ヶ月目みたいないやこれは
ラグジじゃないねノットだノットラグジ
おらよし次はベッドをまず2つ入れます俺
のイメージなんかここと
ここなんだよなえベッドはラゲージはで
ないコラマットレスを使用しており
[音楽]
ます照明の数がラ
のまた照明が増えた照明うるさすぎる電気
消したらおしいやほんまに消してみていい
おお光ってるそれは
そう
まあ確かにねまあまあだねね高いやつだ
からねそうそうだよいいんだよいいんだよ
これ高いだけでエレガントだから高いだけ
でエレガントうん思ったてとと
違う行きますはい
うわあうわあ
うわうわ
あスイートルーム完成しましたまだまだ
至らない部分改造し足りない部分あると
思うんですけども現状できる最大限のあ
ラグジュアリー整えたと思います早速行き
ましょうそれでは開けます
[音楽]
こちら
はいというわけでめちゃくちゃ
しました初め社長の4君の豪邸スイート
ルーム
ですあのねベッド2個置いた瞬間も場所が
なくなってマジで終わったって思ったん
ですけど意外とあの奥側のスペース
しっかり有効活用してラグジュアでな感じ
にはまとめれたと思いますまずねこっちの
壁にですね棚を設置しました結構なんか
好きなものを詰め込んだ感じにしました僕
が一番好きなゲームマザー2のオネットっ
ていう街の絵なんかあとはこういうなんか
好きなものとかを色々置いて飾ってあり
ますこういう一定物の置き方するとすごい
かっこよく映るのでなんかこれは良い気が
しましたそしてこっちこっちはもうかなり
変わった気がしますなんかめっちゃ
ビビットなラインが入った立体型なロー
テーブルで鏡とかソファーを置いてここに
テレビこれでこうやってテレビとかゲーム
とか座りながらできる飲み食いしながら
できるっていう感じですそしてこの後ろの
えめっちゃくちゃ良くないですか東京芸術
大学の米山さんという方の作品をこちらに
飾らせていただきました東京芸術大学って
知ってますもう今や日本の芸術のトップな
トップって言えばいいのかわかんないん
ですけどもやばい人の絵をここに飾らせて
いただきましたなんかその人赤い絵しか
書かなくてで俺赤がすごい好きなので
変わった形の机だったりソファーがあっ
たりめちゃくちゃ曲がった正面があったり
とかなんか形をすごいイメージした部屋
っぽかったので形というか空間的な絵を
ちょっといいてこちらに飾らせていた
いただきました設置までしていただきまし
たありがとうござい
ますいすげえ
な逆だな逆かあ違います全然違います
ソファが青でこの絵が赤だからちょっと色
のバランスが喧嘩するかなと思ったんです
けど逆に逆に喧嘩させていいんじゃないか
と強い色をバーンと2つ置いてみました
気持ちは熱く行動はクールにうんそして
ベッドが2つうこれねそろそろ新しい
ベッドに変えようと思っててすいません
間に合いませんでしたこのベッドずっと
使っててそろそろ新しいのにしようと思っ
たんですけどもちょっと間に合わなかった
のでこれはでもいずれ近いうちにベッド
変えたいと思いますで間にこういうサイド
テーブルとか置いたりしてますあのここに
しか置く場所がなかったのですみっこに
ピチュー置かせていただきましたこれも
ラグジあり関係なくもう俺の趣味だね愛愛
で置かせていただきましたというわけで
新しい新質というかなんか落ち着ける
部屋づくりこれにて完成ですあベッドは
買います絶対あの近々シモ酢とかになっ
てると思うんで今後はここでなんか寝たり
とかちょっと休んだりゲームしたり
Netflix見たりとかしたいと思い
ますえちょっと待ってくださいはじめさん
じゃあなた撮影はどこでするんですか
あなた今までそこで撮影してましたよね
撮影どうするんですかって思った皆さん
安心してくださいえこちらに撮影スペース
作りましたここで編集もできるし撮影は
もうここでなんかてバーンてまここに
バーンと座って撮影したいと思いますはい
これではめ社長の2023年の動画最後に
なりますえ皆さん今年もはめ社長
ありがとうございましたまあ色々ありまし
たねえ年間通してYouTubeのシト
動画が1位なんやかんや初めち今年1位
撮ってましたショート動画ででゲーム部門
も3位あんまり自覚なかったですけどそれ
なりに結果を残せた1連だったのかなと
思いますあとは大きな変化としてはコラボ
禁止だね今年1年間コラボ待って待って
コラボ禁止してショート動画1位最強
わかんないですけどねなんかそのコラボし
ないコラボしないで取りたい字は格別だ
なって思いましたコラボ禁止で寂しい思い
もしたりわなんかあの人とこういう動画
撮ったら面白いなっていう発想もあったん
ですけど1年通して思っ
た俺は1人が似合ってる誰かと撮る動画も
楽しいですけど来年からも別にそんな
コラボめっちゃする予定はないです
めっちゃ上からで申し訳ないんですけども
コラボしましょって誰かから言われて
コラボするんじゃなくてもう俺がコラボし
たいですっていう人としかコラボしない
ようにしたいなって今年1年通して思い
ましたねあとは初め社長の畑の休止無期限
活動休止ですねま色々こう考えながらも
変化した1年だったなと思いますそして気
になるHIKAKINさんの
カウントダウン何なんでしょうねマジで何
なんでしょうとりあえず来年の目標目標と
いうか来年はどうありたいかって言うと
なんか今年尖っていくって言いながら
そんな尖れなかった気がしててなんか尖る
と思ったら思ったより自分が抱えてること
の人とか周りの人の大きさに気づいて
なんか自分の立場を自自覚した1年だった
なって思いましてそうなんかね暴れように
もなんか俺暴れたら色々迷惑かかっちゃう
人とか色々なんか責任感のあるポジション
にいるなってことを今年なんか感じたので
なんか来年は逆にそういうのも踏まえて
お前がそれするんて言われるようなこと
どんどんやっていければいいかなと思い
ますすいませんあの事務所の人とか周りの
人迷惑かけると思いますごめんなさいまだ
尖りきれてなかったなっていう1年だった
気がするので来年はもっと尖った1年に
できればいいかなって思いますたくさんの
人にお世話になっていろんな人に動画を見
てもらった1人でした来年も皆さん
よろしくお願いしますそして年末は逃走中
初め社長出てます見てくださいじゃな年末
電車はスノボに行ってき
ます
[音楽]
T